à quelle heure on y va
c'est la routine comme tous les matins
même pas quand j'aimais les manches
mais aujourd'hui c'est Jessie qui va
porter la petite à la garderie ce qui
implique une logistique supplémentaire
Sonia nous sommes arrivés au matin ça
vient car Jessie et paraplégique or le
milieu de garde comme à peu près tous
les autres n'est pas conçu pour
accueillir les fauteuils roulants Jessy
dépend obligatoirement de l'aide de
l'éducatrice pour déposer sa petite le
statu quo le normal c'est que ce n'est
pas accessible du tout il y a des
marches il y a pas de rampe il y a pas
d'ascenseurs l'organisme exéco ne
quantifie pas le phénomène mais affirme
que beaucoup de parents se butent à ces
obstacles ça limite beaucoup l'autonomie
des parents en situation de handicap il
y a aucune norme là qui dit que les
milieux de garde doivent être
accessibles il y a rien qui va régir ça
leur demande que Québec profite de la
refonte de la place 0,50 pour inclure
l'information faute de pouvoir rendre
tous les milieux de garde accessibles la
plupart des milieux de garde serait
vraiment ouvert à adapter leur
environnement mais c'est l'argent puis
c'est les moyens qui manquent de la part
du gouvernement
entre temps ce sont les parents comme
Jessie qui est coop en cas d'urgence ou
pour toute étape importante de la vie de
sa petite impossible pour lui d'entrer à
l'intérieur du spectacle chorale dans
une salle que je peux pas accéder ben ça
serait plate c'est la fin du monde mais
oui ce serait le fun que les garderies
qui n'existe au moins que qui soit
entièrement accessible et que si c'est
le cas mais là quelqu'un comme moi aura
une priorité pour y aller y accéder
cause de la famille
sous inclure l'information dans le
nouveau guichet unique ici qui me
permettra au Canada Montréal